Le Café de
l'Espace des sciences, avec la revue
Science Ouest,
Bonsoir à toutes et à tous,
Merci d'être au rendez vous pour ce Café
des sciences ce soir,
un café des sciences
organisé par l'équipe
de la rédaction du magazine Science Ouest.
Merci à vous, Yves Le Loir,
d'avoir accepté notre invitation.
Vous êtes chercheur à l'Institut
national de recherche
pour l'agriculture, l'alimentation
et l'environnement, l'Inrae
et vous êtes aussi directeur
du laboratoire STLO
aux sciences et technologies
du lait et de l'œuf.
C'est tout bon.
Jusqu'ici, ce soir, avec vous,
on va parler des ferments.
Donc ce sont ces micro-organismes
qu'on retrouve dans le pain,
la bière, la choucroute,
le fromage ou encore le vin.
Au total, les produits fermentés.
Ils représentent 30%
de notre alimentation.
Aujourd'hui,
ça fait presque 10 000 ans qu'on les utilise
et on va donc pouvoir faire le point
sur ce qu'est la fermentation,
son histoire, son rôle aussi, mais aussi
les défis qu'elle pose aujourd'hui.
Et vous qui êtes dans le public,
eh bien, comme d'habitude,
n'hésitez pas à poser vos questions
tout au long de cet échange
il y a un micro qui circulera parmi vous.
Et peut être pour commencer, une question
toute simple mais importante Yves Le Loir,
qu'est ce que la fermentation
alors ?
La fermentation.
D'un point de vue biochimique
ou microbiologique, c'est
l'utilisation d'un substrat,
d'une source d'énergie
qui est le plus souvent du sucre
pour la transformer en une autre.
Notre forme, qui est le plus souvent
un acide
ou un alcool, et
les acteurs de cette fermentation là
sont les micro-organismes et quelque chose
qui caractérise la fermentation
par rapport à la respiration,
c'est l'absence d'oxygène.
Donc il n'y a pas d'oxygène,
il y a du sucre par exemple,
on met des micro-organismes
et on obtient un produit qui contient
beaucoup moins de sucres,
mais qui par contre, c'est acidifier
ou c'est enrichi en alcool ?
Ça dépend du substrat
et des micro-organismes choisis.
Des ferments
justement, qui sont ces ferments là ?
Est ce qu'ils ont déjà ?
Combien est ce qu'ils sont ?
Est ce qu'on
les connaît tous aujourd'hui ?
Alors tous, non.
Il y a encore plein, plein, plein,
plein de choses à découvrir.
Par contre, on en connaît quand même
pas mal parce que ça fait longtemps,
comme vous disiez
qu'on travaille sur la fermentation,
qu'on utilise la fermentation,
alors le rôle de la fermentation,
basiquement,
c'est de conserver de la matière première.
Donc donner la possibilité,
si on remonte longtemps en arrière,
c'est donner la possibilité à des gens
d'utiliser du lait
bien longtemps après avoir trait la vache,
parce que c'est une denrée
qui est très périssable, le lait.
Certains végétaux aussi
sont très périssables
et du coup, un moyen
de mettre à disposition cette nourriture
là longtemps après la récolte
ou après la traite, c'est de fermenter.
Alors,
il y a d'autres moyens de conservation
des aliments qui existent et à la cuisson.
C'était une des premières
aussi à apparaître.
Il y a la salaison,
on met beaucoup de sel et ça conserve.
Il y a la pasteurisation, la stérilisation
dans le traitement thermique.
Et puis je pense que j'ai fait
à peu près le Tour.
Tout ça a contribué à mettre à disposition
de la
de la de la nourriture bien longtemps
après l'avoir produite réellement
et du
coup,
les différents types de fermentation,
ça va être des fermentations
qui vont donner des acides.
J'en ai un peu parlé,
donc transformer du lait en fromage,
ça va être principalement lié
à la fermentation lactique.
Alors on dit lactique
parce que le lait, on dit lactique
parce que la nature de l'acide produit,
c'est l'acide lactique.
On peut faire de la fermentation lactique
sur des végétaux.
La choucroute, c'est
une fermentation lactique.
On prend du chou, on le hache.
Il y a des bactéries lactiques
qui se nourrissent de tout ça
et qui transforment les sucres.
Le peu de sucres présents dans le chou
en acide lactique.
Et ce faisant,
ça nous permet de conserver du choux
longtemps, longtemps
après la récolte même du chou.
L'ensilage,
c'est le même principe pour les vaches
on prend du maïs, on le coupe,
les bactéries poussent là dessus,
on met des bâches dessus
pour que ce soit à l'abri de l'oxygène.
Ça fermente, ça donne de l'acide lactique
et c'est une fermentation lactique.
Il y a là
d'autres types de fermentation, opérée
cette fois ci plus par des levures.
C'est
la fermentation alcoolique ou éthylique.
Ou là, les levures vont utiliser
le sucre du végétal,
donc le grain de raisin.
Le blond de la bière pour le digérer
et former cette fois ci
non pas de l'acide lactique,
mais de l'éthanol.
Et donc cette fermentation la provoque.
Aujourd'hui, l'homme la provoque.
C'est un processus naturel toutefois qu'on
provoque pour conserver des aliments
pour produire, pour les transformer,
mais pas, par exemple,
un fruit qui tombe d'un arbre.
Il fermente ?
Oui, peut être.
Oui, oui, il fermente une
une pomme qui tombe de l'arbre
et qu'on cueille quelques jours après.
Il va sentir un peu
le cidre quand même, puis la pomme.
Et de la même façon,
les lacto fermentation végétales
qui sont à la mode en ce moment.
Les légumes fermentés,
les pickles qu'on fait à la maison,
c'est de la fermentation spontanée,
donc, avec les bactéries lactiques
qui sont présentes à la surface,
des fruits qu'on va hacher,
qui vont en mettant un peu d'eau,
un tout petit peu de saumure
fermenter vos carottes,
vos betteraves, des radis.
On peut fermenter un peu tout à la maison,
on peut faire des mélanges
et puis vous permettre
de consommer ces carottes, ces betteraves,
et cetera Plusieurs mois après, après la,
après la récolte
et la plupart du temps,
c'est la fermentation.
Initialement,
cette fermentation était spontanée.
Et puis après, avec l'évolution,
en voulant diriger vraiment
vers tel ou tel type de fermentation,
on a ensemencé.
Alors, soit parce qu'on a trouvé que
on peut imaginer les premiers,
les premiers fermenteurs.
Les premiers technologues
ont vu que finalement, le résultat
final était pas mal.
Donc ils ont pris un petit bout
du résultat final et ils l'ont utilisé
pour ensemencer le nouveau.
Le nouvel arrivage de lait ou
donc ils se sont dit finalement
si je prends
le résultat qui est pas mal,
que je l'utilise pour remettre
assermenté dents dans ce lait frais, j'ai
de bonnes chances
de retrouver le produit laitier
fermenté qui m'a bien plu.
Et puis après encore
on a, on sait, on s'est arrangé pour soit
faire un traitement thermique au lait
ou le filtrer
pour enlever toutes les bactéries
dont les bactéries pathogènes
qui pouvaient être très gênantes
pour les consommateurs. Évidemment.
Et alors
là, pour le coup, on en est très propre
et là il faut tout, tout ré ensemencer.
Donc quand on veut
une fermentation lactique,
eh bien on sélectionne
les bonnes bactéries lactiques
pour avoir, avec l'aide de la technologie
aussi plein de plein d'étapes
pour avoir le fromage qui nous intéresse.
Oui, bonjour.
Quelle différence
entre un levain du boulanger
et la levure
qui peut être ajoutée à la pâte
à la pâte, à la boite pour faire le pain
dans une boulangerie ?
La préparation au levain est différente
des levures utilisées
en boulangerie.
En panification,
ce n'est pas trop mal parti,
mais c'est effectivement.
C'est une levure qui est qui fait ça.
Souvent,
les boulangers achètent leur levure
et puis ils l'utilisent
un peu, un peu à la mode
de ce que je vous ai expliqué.
Ils prennent une, prennent une partie de
la précédente fermentation
et puis ils ensemence leur nouveau,
leur nouveau pétrin.
Est ce que mes grands parents
étaient boulangers ?
Alors j'ai vu la préparation du levain
préparer un morceau de peau.
Il le laissait, commence à l'air et puis
le laissait fermenter naturellement.
Et puis l'alimentaire
et rajouter un peu de pâte pour
préparer un levain pour
mélanger à la pâte de sa fournée,
c'est ça ?
Mais il laisser reposer un certain temps
avant de l'employer, il faut.
Il faut quand même le temps
au levain de se multiplier.
Voilà
comment il se multiplie dans sa pâte.
Quoi ? C'est ça ?
Il faut lui donner à manger.
Et une fois qu'il a suffisamment,
voilà qu'il est arrivé à un bon à bon
niveau de densité.
Hop, on peut ensemencer cette fois ci
tout un pétrin pour lancer la fermentation
et la nouvelle fournée est toujours
et toujours toujours en garder.
Oui, alors ça, c'est des choses qui,
ce sont des choses qu'on fait encore.
On a eu un projet, nous, sur le gouel,
qui est un lait fermenté
typique du Finistère,
avec du lait de pie noire bretonne
et les artisans qui font du gouel.
Et ils ont exactement cette démarche
de toujours garder leur ferment.
Ils aliment tout les tous les jours,
tous les jours,
ils partent en vacances avec eux.
C'est toujours ils,
c'est eux qui l'alimente tous les jours
et ils ré ensemence leur lait
depuis noire bretonne pour faire le gouet,
une sorte de lait ribot un peu dense.
En fait, tout ce que
ce qu'il y a.
D'autres questions, pas.
Oui, vous êtes chercheur en fermentation
et je voulais savoir.
Vous cherchez quoi sur la fermentation ?
Y a t il encore des choses
à trouver sur la fermentation ?
Il y a plein plein de choses
à trouver sur la fermentation.
Parce que alors, au delà de cet aspect
préservation,
il y a aussi
toutes les modifications organoleptiques.
Donc on part.
C'est quand même assez magique de
s'imaginer qu'avec trois choses, du lait,
des micro-organismes et de la technologie,
c'est la main de l'homme.
À quel quel,
quel traitement je faire à un mollet ?
Est ce que je vais y goûter plus,
se laisser reposer le cahier,
mettre en cave chaud à froid,
jouer sur les températures, et cetera
Donc avec trois choses du lait,
des micro-organismes et de la technologie.
Rien que sur cette matière première là,
on fait des dizaines et des dizaines
ou des centaines de fromages et
de produits laitiers fermentés différents.
Donc il y a tous ces processus là
qu'on contrôle plus ou moins bien,
qu'on cherche à standardiser
ou au contraire complètement enrichir.
C'est des choses
qu'on ne maîtrise pas encore tout à fait.
On comprend pas tous les processus
et il y a encore plein de choses
à chercher pour comprendre
et mieux mieux maîtriser ça.
Et puis après, Au delà de
cette transformation de la matière
première, on a juste un aliment.
Il y a aussi tout l'aspect nutritionnel
parce qu'il
y a des apports aussi
liés à ces processus fermentés.
Donc il y a des vitamines
qui sont dans les produits fermentés
et qui ne sont pas dans la matière
première d'origine.
Et ça, c'est
la contribution des micro-organismes.
Il y a le fait de changer de par le pH,
donc c'est l'acidité
ou des choses comme ça, de changer un peu
le milieu physico chimique.
Ça va permettre
de rendre plus biodisponible
certains micronutriments du lait
ou des végétaux.
Et puis de la nutrition,
on glisse vers la santé.
Et puis là, des levains d'acide lactique.
Pendant bactéries lactiques, on passe à la
catégorie des bactéries probiotiques.
Donc ces bactéries qui, lorsqu'on
les ingère, en plus de l'apport
nutritionnel lié à l'aliment qui
les contient, nous donnent un effet santé,
un bien être digestif.
Voilà des aspects anti-inflammatoires.
On en entend beaucoup
parler autour des maladies inflammatoires
chroniques de l'intestin,
tout ce spectre de maladies là.
On entend beaucoup
parler des solutions probiotiques
pour essayer d'atténuer
les symptômes de ces maladies là.
Donc, sur ces aspects là,
il y a beaucoup,
beaucoup de beaucoup de choses
à découvrir.
Merci.
Peut être pour continuer
la discussion au niveau du labo
où vous êtes.
Est ce que il y a certaines découvertes ?
Je ne sais pas si vous avez fait
des découvertes qui auraient eu
une implication
dans la société civile après par la suite.
C'est à dire que ce que vous avez
pu mettre en avant,
ça a été repris par
une SATT ou autre qui fait
du développement de la valorisation.
Est ce que vos recherches ont eu un impact
plus plus général et qui s'est diffusé ?
Ajouté.
Oui, je vous réponds en deux temps.
Juste sur la démarche de la recherche
en général.
C'est vrai qu'on travaille
beaucoup sur des on est une ré,
on est plutôt un institut de recherche
finalisé, on va dire.
Il faut que nos nos travaux
servent à quelque chose et bien souvent,
on travaille plutôt sur
des projets de recherche pré compétitif,
c'est à dire de la connaissance générique
qui peut servir à tous.
Quand je dis à tous à diffuser
à la société comme ce que je fais là,
diffuser à la communauté scientifique
et diffuser aux industriels, donc
ça leur permet de progresser, de gagner
des points de compétitivité et tout.
Maintenant, vous dire exactement
lequel de nos résultats
a été réellement mis en application, ça,
il nous accompagne beaucoup.
Ils nous aident à
y compris financièrement, sur des projets
de recherche très compétitifs
dès lors qu'on est dans le registre
de la recherche compétitive,
ils nous disent plus rien.
Donc alors, très concrètement,
il y a des choses sans que je puisse
vous citer des produits.
Là, je vais rentrer plus dans ce
que je fais dans mon quotidien,
ce qu'on fait au labo, parce que,
en réalité,
je ne suis pas tellement à la paillasse.
Mais très concrètement,
une problématique très, très quotidienne.
C'est tout ce qui touche aux produits
laitiers fermentés, dont l'usage est
assez répété comme un pot de crème fraîche
ou un sachet de méthyle râpé.
Donc vous l'achetez, vous le consommer ?
Pas en une seule fois et bien souvent,
une fois ouvert,
c'est sujet à contamination.
Donc il y a des pros pour le coup.
Là, c'est des moisissures de type
qui ne sont pas spécialement dangereuses
mais qui modifient le goût.
Et quand sur un paquet de fromage râpé,
vous avez un peu de Penicillium
qui pousse, vous avez un hématome,
le râpé qui sent le roquefort et c'est
pas terrible pour vos pâtes.
Si vous n'avez pas ça quoi.
C'est pas dangereux
mais c'est pas terrible.
Les clients n'aiment pas ça.
Et pour éviter ces contaminations
fongiques, fongiques là sur
type fromage râpé ou ou
crème fraîche, pour l'instant,
les industriels n'ont pas d'autre choix
que de mettre des additifs
type nata, Miskine ou samba,
dont ils savent que
ça ne sera peut être pas interdit.
Ce sera fortement limité
et puis interdit d'ici peu.
Donc ils essayent de prévenir ça
et nous interroge.
Qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire
pour éviter ça ?
Donc ce sont des produits fermentés.
Donc on a fait un gros travail
sur une banque de bactéries lactiques
qu'on a au labo,
qui nous a permis de sélectionner
des souches qui étaient capables
de fermenter de la crème fraîche
ou de faire de l'émail,
mais qui en plus avaient
des propriétés antifongiques.
Donc, ce qui permettait de s'affranchir
de ces additifs là, tout
en proposant au public un fromage râpé
qu'on peut utiliser sur deux semaines
ou une boîte de crème fraîche
qu'on peut ouvrir.
Et puis, et peut être même l'oublier
deux ou 3 h sur le plan de travail
avant de la remettre au frigo.
Donc ça, c'est
des propriétés antifongiques, naturelles.
On a sélectionné des dès le vin
pour faire ça.
On est parti de plus de 700 souches
pour arriver à une combinaison
de trois ou quatre souches seulement.
Et puis là s'arrête
le projet de recherche pré compétitif.
On propose ça à des industriels
qui le mettent en œuvre, mais jamais
ils nous font en retour.
Ça, c'est leur secret industriel
et c'est plus notre business, ça.
Voilà, ça, c'est un exemple.
Et puis il y a quelque chose
qui est beaucoup plus récent
et sur lesquels aussi on est interrogé.
C'est cet engouement
pour les fermentations végétales.
Alors on maîtrise
très bien, on en parlait et on maîtrise
très bien chez nous, en Occident,
les fermentations.
Plutôt sur de la matière
première animale, le lait.
Et puis les produits carnés,
les saucissons.
On maîtrise plutôt bien.
Et cette culture là
de la fermentation végétale,
c'est plutôt les Asiatiques
qui qui l'ont développé.
Ils sont très forts là dedans.
Et puis nous,
on est de plus en plus interrogés.
On nous demande qu'est
ce que vous pouvez faire là dessus ?
Et puis il y a des spécialités
qui sont qui sont encore émergentes
mais où on compte proposer
des produits mixtes
qui mélangent dans un fromage, par exemple
à la fois du lait
et puis du végétal, avec des farines
très, très riches en protéines
qui permettront de substituer
une partie de la protéine animale
par de la protéine végétale est le but.
In fine,
c'est de faire appel à de l'élevage.
Pour avoir une agriculture
et une alimentation
plus vertueuse, il faut qu'on végétalisme,
notre alimentation
et ces mix animaux végétaux là.
Donc lait,
plus des farines de légumineuses,
c'est un moyen d'aller
peut être pas directement végétal,
mais peut être graduellement
vers une alimentation
plus végétalisée et donc plus vertueuse
pour l'environnement
et la santé et accessoirement
pour.
Je sais pas s'il y a d'autres questions
tout de suite.
On peut être tout à l'heure.
Du coup,
quand vous travaillez
sur la végétalisation de l'alimentation,
c'est une demande des entreprises ou c'est
une demande citoyenne
des politiques publiques ?
Ou c'est vous qui vous dites.
Là, vu le contexte,
il faut aller dans ce sens.
Là bas, c'est un peu tout. A vrai dire,
je pense que c'est une réelle nécessité.
Ça, c'est
quelque chose dont on a tous conscience.
Donc manger moins de produits animaux,
substituer ça par plus de protéines.
Je parle de protéines, mais c'est
essentiellement que là sont les enjeux.
Substituer
ça par plus de protéines végétales.
Et du coup, avoir une moindre pression
sur des aspects
agriculture élevage intensif
au profit de productions végétales
qui sont un peu plus vertueuses.
Et puis donc, il y a
une dimension très politique là dedans.
Il y a une demande sociétale
et des consommateurs pour ces produits là.
Et puis du coup,
les industriels, ils suivent.
Et même
des industriels laitiers
qui, il y a dix ans, disait
Mais je ne veux pas entendre
parler de ces trucs là.
C'est la perte, c'est
la perte de l'industrie laitière.
En fait, ils s'y mettent,
certains s'y mettent
pour chercher.
Et donc c'est ce qu'on disait au début.
Il y a une quantité absolument
phénoménale de micro-organismes qui jouent
un rôle dans la fermentation qu'on connaît
quasiment toutes aujourd'hui.
Mais aujourd'hui,
le travail des scientifiques,
c'est ce que vous vous disiez ?
Ce n'est plus d'aller
chercher ces nouveaux micro-organismes
qui qui jouent un rôle
dans la fermentation, mais c'est d'essayer
d'en combiner plusieurs
pour voir quels apports
ils peuvent présenter
avec ces associations là.
Oui, c'est ça.
Pendant longtemps,
on a cherché à décrire les espèces
et puis toute la diversité des espèces.
Et une fois qu'on a bien maîtrisé
ces concepts là,
on est allé voir au niveau infra espèce.
La notion de souche.
Ici, on fait tous partie de la même espèce
les hommes
et pourtant on est tous différents
avec des propriétés différentes.
Chez les bactéries,
c'est exactement la même chose.
Donc sur les deux espèces de bactéries
par exemple, on en parlait tout à l'heure
yaourt, Streptococcus
thermophiles, Lactobacillus, Bulgarie.
On peut décliner ça avec plein
de petites variantes, en gardant toujours
les deux mêmes espèces,
mais en choisissant bien les souches.
On peut avoir des yaourts
qui vont être plus doux ou plus acides,
qui vont avoir un filon
ou ils vont être plus cassants.
Voilà, il y a.
On peut, on peut.
On peut jouer là dessus
sur cette diversité là pour aussi
augmenter
le panel de produits disponibles.
Alors ce sur quoi on est interrogé là,
c'est maintenant comment on choisit
intelligemment chacune de ces souches
là pour les combiner
et les amener vers le produit
qu'on veut, soit le produit qu'on veut,
soit le composé
qu'on veut que le produit contienne.
Donc ça peut être des vitamines,
des micronutriments ou des effets santé.
J'ai parlé de propriétés
anti-inflammatoires, par exemple.
Et ceux alors
là, on vient sur des domaines
beaucoup plus scientifiques.
Ce qu'on fait actuellement pour éviter
d'avoir à faire plein de combinaisons
complètement empiriques.
En attendant d'avoir le bon produit
avec le bon composé,
on essaie de le faire
le plus, le plus rapidement et le plus de
la façon la plus économe possible
en se basant sur les génomes.
Donc, la plupart de ces bactéries là, même
quasiment toutes,
sont intégralement séquencé.
On sait ce qu'elles ont dans le ventre
en termes de gènes.
Et puis on va pouvoir les combiner
sur l'acte, sur la prédiction
de leur capacité métabolique.
C'est des mots un peu barbares,
mais si on veut qu'elles produisent
de la vitamine B12, par exemple,
on sait que telle bactérie,
on connaît exactement tout
de la voie de biosynthèse
de la vitamine B12.
On sait qu'il y a plus de dix étapes.
On sait qu'il y a pas mal de gènes
qui sont indiqués, qui sont impliqués.
Et pour
autant, toutes les bactéries vont être
ou ne vont pas avoir
la totalité de ces gènes là.
Dans ce qu'on essaye de faire, c'est
si je prends de l'espèce
qui va me faire telle
ou telle partie de la voie métabolique
et arriver à cet intermédiaire là.
Et bien j'imagine que par diffusion,
elle va aller dans telle autre espèce
et la voie de biosynthèse
va pouvoir se poursuivre.
Et éventuellement je fais appel
à une troisième espèce pour boucler
pour arriver du composé précurseur
jusqu'à la vitamine B12.
Ce qui m'intéresse, ce sont des choses
qu'on essaie de mettre en place.
On a des projets là dessus en ce moment.
Ça demande pas mal de travail
au niveau bioinformatique,
mais une fois que ça marche
à peu près bien, on gagne énormément,
énormément de temps
sur la sélection de ces de ces espèces
pour les combiner et les amener
à produire quelque chose ensemble.
Donc ça, on le fait
vraiment en se basant sur la biodiversité.
Donc on utilise les bactéries telles
qu'elles sont, on les prend
avec ce qu'elles sont et on les combine
pour les amener à faire ce qu'on veut.
Une autre possibilité,
ce serait de la pure biotechnologie
et ça serait de prendre les gènes
qui nous intéressent et les mettre
pour compléter les voies de biosynthèse
qui manquent dans une autre.
Mais là, ce n'est pas du tout,
ce n'est pas notre domaine.
Là, c'est de la biotechnologie
et ce n'est pas
c'est
pas dans le registre de l'alimentaire là.
Justement,
à propos de ce genre de produits là,
vous parliez du microbiote tout à l'heure.
Quel apport avez vous découvert
pour justement améliorer les probiotiques
et rééquilibrer
le microbiote de ceux qui en ont besoin ?
Ça, c'est ça, C'est là pour vous.
Pour le coup,
c'est tout un champ de la science
qui est super intéressant
tout neuf et ce qu'est ce qu'on fait.
Ce qu'on fait là pour l'instant,
c'est qu'on s'applique.
Ce n'est pas nous, c'est d'autres.
D'autres laboratoires s'appliquent
à comprendre les relations qu'il
y a entre notre microbiote
et notre état de santé.
Déjà déjà, on en découvre tous les jours,
donc ça, un microbiote en bonne santé,
il faut déjà être capable de le définir.
Et puis, après les déséquilibres
qu'il y a au sein de ce microbiote
qu'on appelle des bio,
c'est un terme un peu barbare.
Mais voilà, c'est
un microbiote en déséquilibre.
Pour l'instant, on fait des corrélations.
Mais corrélation,
ce n'est pas une causalité.
Donc on sait que
quand il manque
ou quand on a telle espèces
qui sont beaucoup moins abondantes
dans un microbiote, on sait qu'on
peut corréler ça à des miki, par exemple,
ces fameuses maladies
inflammatoires chroniques de l'intestin.
Mais ça peut aussi être corrélé
à des cas de diabète
de type deux, à des obésité.
Alors ça va jusqu'à le spectre autistique.
Il y a un tas d'études qui montrent qu'il
y a une relation entre
l'état de santé de notre microbiote
et notre état de santé à bien des égards,
pas uniquement sur des choses
qui touchent strictement le tube digestif,
mais qui touchent des maladies du foie,
des maladies du cerveau, des maladies
des poumons.
Il y a un tas de choses
et un tas de corrélations qui sont faites.
Maintenant,
c'est Hippocrate.
On attribue ça à Hippocrate qui disait
Ton aliment sera ta première médecine
est un médecine,
ton aliment un truc dans le genre.
En gros,
c'est notre nourriture qui est qui
est notre premier médicament.
Et sur cette base là,
il y a plein de gens qui sont intéressés.
Mais finalement,
quand on mange des aliments fermentés,
est ce qu'on n'apporte pas aussi à travers
toutes ces bactéries qu'on ingère ?
Est ce qu'on n'apporte pas aussi
des bonnes bactéries qui vont compléter
ou modifier légèrement notre
notre microbiote intestinal ?
On en est au début de ça, c'est à dire
le levier de l'alimentation pour rétablir
un équilibre au niveau intestinal.
On en est au début.
Ce qu'on sait par contre,
c'est que clairement,
quand on mange des aliments fermentés,
quel qu'il soit,
on apporte beaucoup de bactéries
et que ça a un impact,
au moins transitoire, sur les équilibres
au niveau du microbiote.
Déjà, au niveau de la diversité,
les espèces présentes
et au niveau de ce qu'elle exprime aussi.
C'est à dire que ce qu'on appelle
le métabolisme,
c'est tous les métabolites
qu'elles sont capables de produire.
Il ne va pas être le même selon
qu'on a une diète
riche en aliments fermentés ou zéro
aliments fermentés.
Ça, ça a été montré expérimentalement.
Maintenant, est ce qu'on peut réellement
s'en servir comme levier pour rétablir
une dose bio et du coup,
atténuer des effets de Miki, par exemple ?
Je ne pense pas
qu'on en soit tout à fait là quand même.
Et de manière générale,
est ce qu'on peut dire est ce que c'est
vrai de dire que consommer des produits
fermentés, c'est bon pour la santé ?
Ou est ce qu'il faut plus nuancer ?
Ah si, globalement,
les études montrent que oui,
ça apporte, ça apporte du
plein de choses sur
elles, sur les aspects nutritionnels
et puis
les aspects santé.
Selon les souches probiotiques ou pas,
qui sont contenues dans l'aliment
fermenté, on peut.
On peut attendre un mieux être.
Il y a beaucoup d'études
qui sont menées là dessus.
La plupart vont jusqu'à l'animal.
Donc c'est des essais
sur sur la souris, sur le rat
ou on voit des effets spectaculaires
dans Transposez ça sur l'homme,
il y a encore du chemin.
C'est souvent des choses
qui sont très très coûteuses
et qui sont difficiles à financer.
Quand on parle
d'effets spectaculaires, c'est quoi ?
Par curiosité ?
Là bas, ça peut être par exemple des
des effets préventifs vis à vis
d'inflammation du tube digestif
chez la souris par exemple.
Donc on peut.
On peut déclencher Chez la souris
avec un traitement de type médicamenteux,
on peut déclencher une inflammation
de type rectocolite hémorragique,
ou plutôt de type maladie de Crohn,
et cetera Et du coup, ce terrain là, c'est
un terrain de jeu pour les scientifiques
et les microbiologie
pour tester l'effet bénéfique
de leurs bactéries, évidemment.
Donc on les applique
soit à titre préventif, c'est à dire
qu'on va donner les bactéries probiotiques
constamment à un groupe de souris
qui va avoir cet aliment fermenté
ou ces bactéries là et avec un groupe
contrôle qui ne les aura pas.
Et puis on va induire l'inflammation
et on va avoir quel impact ça va avoir
sur l'état de santé général des souris ?
Et en général,
on a des effets assez positifs.
Donc ça, c'est des choses
que je qualifierais de presque classiques.
Et puis, au delà de ça, il y a des
des choses qui sont spectaculaires,
qui sont de l'ordre de
jouer sur
l'équilibre du microbiote intestinal.
Mais quand on arrive à modifier de façon
assez drastique,
voire transplanter le microbiote
d'une souris saine vers une souris malade,
on a des effets spectaculaires
en matière de soi, plutôt curatifs.
Donc on soigne les symptômes
ou préventifs,
c'est à dire
qu'on va empêcher la maladie d'arriver.
C'est,
je ne sais pas si, à d'autres questions,
vous parliez du coût
des bienfaits par rapport
notamment aux souris et des inflammations.
Je suppose que c'est principalement
pour tout ce qui est fermentation acide.
Mais est ce qu'on a la même chose
pour les fermentation alcoolique,
qui sont plutôt réputées
pour créer des inflammations ?
Alors on a eu
les expériences dont je vous ai parlé.
C'est vraiment centré
sur le microbiote intestinal
et évidemment, il se passe
un tas de fermentation là dedans.
Est on a quitté quand même
le domaine de l'aliment fermenté
et l'impact de l'ingestion de
d'aliments fermentés sur le microbiote.
Déjà, on est en train de le documenter
et secondairement l'impact de l'aliment
fermenté sur le microbiote,
puis sur l'état de santé des souris.
Où tout ça.
Il y a encore plein
plein de choses à explorer et moi,
je ne suis pas suffisamment à l'aise et
pointus là dedans.
Pour pour vous répondre.
Bonsoir.
Moi je voulais savoir comment on peut
faire du fromage dans notre cuisine.
Le yaourt,
c'est assez facile avec
les petites yaourtière qu'on peut trouver,
mais le yaourt, je ne sais pas faire.
Donc est ce que vous pouvez m'expliquer
s'il vous plait ?
C'est vrai que le fromage, c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué que le yaourt
parce que finalement le yaourt on prend
un litre de lait, on met les ferments ou
un yaourt
par exemple
et on obtient un litre de yaourt.
On n'a rien enlevé.
On a juste fait que fermenter le fromage.
Là, selon.
Selon le type de fromage que vous voulez,
vous allez avoir des technologies
qui vont être plutôt
dites acides ou des technologies présure
ou les technologies acides.
Ça va être les fromages, le fromage frais
du cottage ou des choses comme ça
ou du fromage blanc,
des fromages typiquement présure.
Ça va être les comtés, les fromages à pâte
pressée, pâte pressée cuite,
comté et métal beaufort.
Et puis, entre.
Entre le fromage frais
et le comté,
il y a toute une gamme des fromages
à pâte molle type camembert.
Et puis des fromages persillé
comme le roquefort ou la fourme d'Ambert,
selon qu'on parle de lait de vache
ou de lait de chèvre ou de lait de brebis.
Voilà, il
y a, si vous me dites
quel genre de fromage
vous voulez, je pourrais peut être être
un peu plus précis dans ma réponse.
Tu racontes un peu ma vie et moi
je n'y connais pas grand chose, même rien.
Mais je me suis amusé
à mettre un peu de jus de citron dans un
dans quelque 1000 litres de lait.
Et puis j'ai goûté pendant 1 h ou deux
et puis ensuite je l'ai
posé sur mon plateau de fromage
où il y avait un peu de roquefort.
Enfin, pas de roquefort, mais un bleu
je ne sais plus lequel.
Du camembert, et puis un comté.
Puis j'ai attendu que quelques jours.
J'ai pas trouvé ça très très bon.
Donc voilà.
Mais j'aimerais bien, moi personnellement,
faire des espèces de faisselle
et des manger frais quoi.
Alors le
Dans la faisselle,
on commence à se diriger
vers le fromage parce qu'on y goûte
la faisselle. Il y a plein de trous. Trop.
Et puis finalement,
le lactosérum commence à quitter le caillé
pour obtenir un caillé qui a.
Encore une fois,
c'est des termes un peu barbares,
mais qui est un extrait sec,
beaucoup plus élevé.
Et quand on parle de faisselle
encore un peu plus sec,
il y a les pas de mole,
mais qui contiennent encore pas mal d'eau.
Tout ça,
ça va être une question d'égouttage.
Finalement.
Et plus on va aller vers des fromages durs
et secs.
Le parmesan, par exemple.
Des fromages de garde qui, fades,
qui s'affinent pendant deux ou trois an,
il va y avoir d'eau.
Et la technologie dont je vous ai parlé
au début,
il faut de la matière première,
des micro-organismes et de la technologie.
Et le fromage ?
Tout le savoir faire
repose sur la technologie
et finalement, on va prendre un lait.
Donc on peut, on peut.
On peut déjà apporter de la variété
avec du lait de vache,
du lait de chèvre, du lait de brebis sous
nos latitudes, mais du lait de chamelle,
du lait de jument, du lait, du lait Diack,
du lait de bufflonne pour la mozzarella.
Et ça peut apporter un peu de diversité.
Il y a les bactéries et puis surtout,
surtout, le fromager et la technologie.
Donc,
dans un
fromage, l'idée c'est d'enlever de l'eau.
Donc on va cailler.
Donc il vous faut des bactéries
pour commencer à acidifier.
On peut pousser et laisser pousser
les bactéries à acidifier.
Et là, on va avoir ce qu'on
appelle un caillé vraiment lactique.
Donc le cahier de lactiques de base,
c'est le yaourt juste.
On enlève rien,
on laisse pousser les bactéries,
ça gélifiant parce que ça, ça signifie.
Et les protéines, elles vont se dénaturer.
Elles vont commencer à se coller
entre elles
et ça va faire ce qu'on appelle un réseau
de protéines, un réseau lactique.
Et puis,
si on veut accélérer et pousser un peu
ce maillage là
entre les protéines de la présure.
Donc là, on commence par les bactéries,
on le laisse travailler un petit peu
et arriver à une certain
un certain degré d'acidité
qui est celui que la présure affectionne.
Pour être bien active,
on met de la présure et alors là,
en 1 h, on a un caillé
qui est ferme, qui est très beau.
Et là,
ce caillé là, il va faire enlever l'eau.
Maintenant, on va le couper,
on le coupe,
ça aide déjà à le mettre dans des moules.
Donc on peut couper
juste avec de l'action, de la louche.
Ça, c'est le camembert moulé à la louche.
On prend dans le cahier
qu'une sorte de flan.
On prend dans le cahier,
on met dans le moule, on remplit le moule.
Et puis, sous l'effet
de juste de la gravité, ça va,
ça va se tasser et hop, un moule,
un moule à camembert, ça à peu près.
Il faut à peu près deux litres.
Cinq pour faire un camembert,
c'est comme ça
et à la fin, on a ça.
Donc on laisse, on laisse l'eau s'écouler.
Et si on veut ça,
ce n'est pas de molle qui contient encore
pas mal d'eau quand même.
Et si on veut passer à des technologies
de type pâte
pressée ou pâte pressée cuite,
pas de pressé, ça porte bien son nom.
Déjà, on ne va pas se contenter
de mouler à la louche
qui fait quand même
des gros paquets de caillé de flan.
Là, on va couper le caillé
et plus on va le couper
en petits cubes,
plus l'égouttage va être fort et rapide.
Et puis, comme quand ça ne suffit pas
et une fois qu'on a tout mis ça
dans les moules,
on va mettre un poids en plus.
D'où la dominance de la dénomination
de fromage à pâte pressée.
Voilà,
on est du coup là, on a des fromages
avec un extrait sec
beaucoup plus important
et du coup, des fromages
qui se gardent aussi bien plus longtemps.
Il y a moins d'eau.
L'activité de l'eau est moindre.
C'est des fromages de garde.
Alors commencez
plutôt par la faisselle
pour votre cuisine.
Après, tenter peut être un camembert là.
De proche en proche, en le mettant à côté
d'un vrai camembert,
il y a la feutrine qui va, qui va,
qui va se mettre dans la croûte fleurie.
C'est
un fromage à pâte molle à croûte fleurie.
ce Penicillium là qui pousse à la surface.
Donc c'est un Penicillium camembert
qui recouvre la surface
et qui participe à l'affinage
du camembert.
Et puis après, pour les pâtes pressées
pas très cuites,
il faut du matos quand même et beaucoup
beaucoup de lait puisqu'on presse la.
Pour faire une meule de mental,
il faut 1000 litres de lait
pour arriver à 40 kilos.
Assez,
c'est du lourd
dans tous les sens du terme.
Une meule des mains à retourner à Saumur
et à essuyer, c'est quelque chose.
Est ce qu'il y a d'autres questions ?
Non, pas pour l'instant,
Monsieur,
Vous égouttez les fromages,
mais l'eau qui s'en écoule est
elle utilisée à quelque chose ?
Et que contient elle ?
Des résidus de bactéries
ou autre choses encore ?
Plein de choses encore
et quels produits en sont faits ?
Peut être à base de cette eau
de récupération ?
Plein de choses encore.
Alors le lactosérum, est ce liquide jaune
alors qui va s'écouler du fait
de l'égouttage ?
Après la formation des cahiers,
on le récupère alors historiquement.
Avant, c'était c'était neutralisé,
épandu ou ça partait,
ça parte à l'égout ou mieux,
ça servait à nourrir les animaux
dans les fermes.
Quand on produisait le lait et on faisait
la fabrication avec le lait du jour.
Et puis, de plus en plus, maintenant,
on valorise
jusqu'à la dernière goutte
chacun des constituants du lait.
Et il se trouve que finalement, cette
fraction protéines qui nous intéresse, là,
c'est vraiment l'or blanc du lait.
Les protéines du lait, c'est
80% de caséine, c'est celles qui servent
à faire ce caillé là qu'on va retrouver
vraiment dans le fromage.
Et puis il y a 20 pour 100 de protéines
qui sont très intéressantes
avec une vraie valeur,
qui sont les protéines sériques,
donc les protéines qui, elles, sont
et qui vont rester,
qui vont partir avec le lactosérum.
Et quand le lactosérum est pas trop acide,
on arrive à les valoriser,
donc on peut les sécher.
Enlever l'eau, les sécher et faire de
la poudre de protéines sériques.
Et cette poudre là,
c'est l'ingrédient principal.
C'est vraiment la base des protéines,
des formules infantiles.
Pour une raison, alors on peut considérer
que la nature est à peu près bien
faite dans la valorisation du lait.
C'est que autant le lait de vache,
il y a quatre 20% de sa fraction
protéines qui est de la caséine.
Donc on va exploiter pour faire du fromage
par exemple.
Et 20% sont des protéines sériques.
Le lait de femme, c'est
l'inverse, c'est quasiment l'inverse.
Les proportions sont pas du tout
les mêmes.
Il y a très peu de caséine,
voire pas du tout,
ou très peu de caséine
dans le lait de femme.
Par contre,
il y a énormément de protéines sériques
d'ailleurs,
alors il y en a qui ont essayé.
Vous pouvez essayer de faire du fromage
avec du lait de femme.
Les rendements sont juste minables,
ça ne marche pas.
Alors
je vous ai parlé d'une exploitation
un peu, un peu un peu technologique.
C'est à dire ?
On va récupérer ce petit lait là,
en extirper les protéines sériques
qui ont une vraie valeur
pour nourrir les bébés.
Parce que c'est la composition, c'est
le type de protéines qui se rapproche
le plus de la protéine maternelle,
finalement du lait maternel
et puis alors plus.
Dans la tradition fromagère,
il y a des fromages de type ricotta
qui sont faits
avec des protéines sériques.
Donc, à ce moment là,
ce qu'on fait, c'est que
c'est la partie soluble des protéines.
Donc ce n'est pas facile à travailler
parce que les faire cailler,
c'est juste impossible à 100 globulaire,
on n'arrive pas à les combiner
à reste solubles.
Donc ce qu'on fait là, c'est
qu'on les chauffe
et la ricotta, Finalement, c'est
du lactosérum qu'on chauffe, qu'on chauffe
et finalement, sous l'effet de la chaleur,
les protéines à se déplacer.
Et puis avant
ça se mettent à interagir entre elles.
Et à nouveau, on va réussir à avoir
un fromage qui est très particulier,
qui est fait principalement
à base de protéines sériques
et qui donne ce
petit côté un peu granuleux,
granuleux.
La ricotta.
La fermentation, c'est
un secteur économique
qui est en plein essor,
qui est très porteur en 2022.
Donc, l'année dernière,
le gouvernement a lancé une plateforme
qui ferments du futur
et qui regroupe plusieurs laboratoires,
dont le vôtre.
L'objectif,
c'est de soutenir la compétitivité
de l'industrie agroalimentaire française,
finançant des recherches
à hauteur de 48 millionsd'euros
sur les ferments.
Pourquoi finalement, est ce que c'est
un secteur sur lequel on investit tant ?
Alors l'idée
dans cet aspect là du plan de relance ?
L'idée, c'était de pousser
encore un peu plus la compétitivité
du secteur industriel français
sur des secteurs
où on était déjà très fort.
Et vous aura pas échappé quand même.
En France On est très fort sur le fromage.
Sans faire de cocorico, c'est vrai,
on est très fort sur le fromage,
on est très forts sur le vin,
on est très forts sur le pain aussi
et sur plein d'autres choses.
La choucroute, on consomme et on produit
énormément de produits fermentés.
En fait, moi je ne parle pas de la bière
et de plein d'autres choses.
Donc il y a il y a un réel
impact
économique de toute cette industrie là.
Et puis et puis en plus, ça répond
aux demandes sociétales dont on parlait
tout à l'heure des des végétaux fermentés
qu'on fait à la maison
ou qu'on trouve de plus en plus,
alors peut être dans des magasins bio,
mais de plus en plus aussi
dans les étals des supermarchés
conventionnels,
on va dire avec une vraie demande
de la part des consommateurs
pour des aliments plus diversifiés.
Il y a un vrai engouement,
c'est vrai pour pour la fermentation.
Donc ça a été porté
au début par quelques chefs toqués
qui qui mettaient au menu
des fermentations qui menaient
chez eux,
dans leur dans leur dans leur cuisine.
Et puis,
et puis, c'est en train de se propager.
Il y a un tas de blogs qui explique
comment on fait des betteraves fermentées,
des Picard,
un tas de choses qui donnent pas à pas
la façon de faire des compositions
de légumes ou de végétaux fermentés,
donc ferments du futur.
À cet aspect.
Là donc, proposer des ferments
pour tous, voilà tout.
Toute cette demande explorée aussi,
justement le lien
entre aliments fermentés, microbiote
et santé des consommateurs.
Alors, pour l'homme,
mais aussi pour l'animal.
Donc J'ai cité le cas de l'ensilage,
mais il y a de plus en plus d'éleveurs
maintenant qui incluent
dans la ration de leurs animaux.
Ça va du poulet à la vache
en passant par le cochon,
une partie,
une partie de l'alimentation fermenté,
pour un peu
pour un tas de choses, notamment.
Ça les aide à avoir moins recours
aux antibiotiques, par exemple,
puisqu'on leur demande aussi
d'être plus vertueux sur ces aspects là.
Donc, là encore, il y a en particulier
sur ces aspects santé là.
Quand je vous le disais,
c'est encore très mal documenté.
Il y a des vrais enjeux derrière
de santé publique de nourrir les gens.
Et puis, il ne faut pas se le cacher,
il y a des marchés à prendre.
Et autant que la France
profite de l'avantage
de la petite avance
qu'elle a pour pousser le curseur
encore un peu plus
et investir dans ce type de recherche là.
Est ce qu'il y a des questions ?
En début de conférence,
vous avez dit que vous étiez
un spécialiste du lait,
mais aussi des oeufs.
Est ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer de façon
très simple
le lien entre fermentation
et il n'y a pas de fermentation de l'œuf
en fait.
Alors, on s'intéresse à la microbiologie
de l'œuf, mais plutôt sur les aspects
néfastes, là, en l'occurrence.
Donc ça va être plutôt ce qu'on
appelle des flore d'altération des flore
qui vont faire
que l'œuf n'est plus consommable.
Pas forcément
parce qu'il est dangereux,
mais parce qu'il a été altéré
par la croissance de certaines bactéries.
Alors
ce à quoi on s'adresse, nous,
c'est vraiment l'œuf des Kasri.
Plutôt
le composé, un peu le côté industriel.
Donc il y a l'œuf coquille
qu'on trouve dans le supermarché.
Et puis toutes les choses à base d'œuf,
les omelettes
qu'on mange à la cantine
pour les enfants dans les Epad et tout ça,
c'est ce sont des nouveaux produits.
Donc ils ont interdiction
d'utiliser des œufs coquilles
pour des questions de contamination
par salmonelle, et cetera
donc pour des raisons
de sécurité sanitaire
et ils se font livrer
des nouveaux produits.
Donc il y a des Kasri qui recueillent
les oeufs et qui cassent les oeufs.
C'est leur métier, c'est tout.
Tout est automatique qu'ils séparent
en blanc, en jaune ou en entier.
Donc par contre, c'est
des bidons de 50 litres aux 100 litres
qui sont livrés soit dans les cantines,
soit aux industriels.
Des gens qui font des macarons,
qui font des îles flottantes,
qui vont dans les supermarchés,
ils cassent pas les oeufs.
Ils se font livrer du blanc
d'œuf qui montent en neige.
Alors là, il y a une vraie problématique
de microbiologie
mais c'est plutôt sur l'altération.
Donc éviter que mon bidon gonfle
et surtout quand je l'ouvre, que ça sente
le ça pour une odeur de pourri,
ça ça parle quand même.
Donc ce n'est pas forcément dangereux,
mais c'est juste
impropre à la consommation.
Personne n'en veut.
Donc on travaille beaucoup là dessus.
Ou alors sur des aspects de sécurité
sanitaire avec principalement salmonelle
parce que salmonelles, c'est
un des résidents
presque très commun
du tube digestif des volailles.
Et comme
l'œuf sort du cloaque de la poule,
il est contaminé avec les fiente
à un moment ou un autre
et il peut être porteur
à la surface de salmonelle.
Et lors du cassage à la maison, ça peut.
Ça peut poser problème.
Donc sur l'œuf,
il n'y a pas de fermentation.
Il y a les œufs de 100 ans qui sont.
C'est que c'est un type de fermentation,
mais c'est
une fermentation chimique.
Donc on parle de fermentation là.
Mais en réalité, ce n'est pas
un processus microbiologique, c'est
vraiment une modification de l'aspect
physico chimique de l'œuf sous l'action
plutôt que de choses basiques basiques
dans le sens de pH.
Au delà de au delà de cette
et peu à peu, l'œuf
va avoir va changer radicalement d'aspect.
Ce n'est pas.
Ce n'est pas hyper beau à voir,
mais en bouche,
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas désagréable.
J'en ai goûté, c'est pas mauvais, ça,
C'est des spécialités chinoises
plutôt,
non ?
J'aimerais juste revenir sur
la fermentation du futur,
c'est à dire où Là,
on se rend compte qu'il y a quand même
un certain nombre de financements qui sont
qui sont proposés.
Et est ce que dans ce contexte
là, sachant qu'en plus en Bretagne
on est quand même une région agricole,
et cetera ?
Est ce que vous vous êtes amené
à développer des recherches,
mais en partenariat
et de façon interdisciplinaire ?
Mais avec plutôt des gens issus
des sciences humaines et sociales ?
Oui. En fait,
quand je vous parlais
de végétaliser notre alimentation,
alors il y a,
il y a tout un gradient entre
du pour 100 animal et du 100% végétal.
Et puis ce qu'on explore, nous
qui est substitut
à une partie de l'animal pour le remplacer
par de la protéine végétale.
Et ça, c'est des produits
qui n'existent pas en réalité.
Donc il y a des questions qu'on se pose
avant de pousser un petit peu.
Alors je parlais un peu technique,
mais avant de monter dans les TRL,
donc le niveau d'application
de nos recherches,
il est opportun de se dire
voilà ce qu'on n'est
pas en train de travailler pour rien.
Parce que si on met au point
un super produit,
mais que les consommateurs
ne sont pas prêts à l'acheter,
ça se vendra pas.
Personne en voudra
et on aura juste travaillé pour le
pour faire avancer la science
éventuellement, mais sans plus.
Et du coup, oui, on s'interroge beaucoup
sur l'acceptabilité
de ces nouveaux produits là.
Alors ça se décline avec des
et essentiellement des panels
de dégustateurs et des questionnaires
qu'on donne aux dégustateurs avec.
Alors, c'est à la fois des aspects
plus sociétaux
et puis des aspects un peu économiques.
Parce qu'il y a des consommateurs
qui sont très enclins à la nouveauté,
qui aiment bien ça.
Et ils vont toujours acheter
les produits laitiers nouveaux.
Ils vont dire
il y a un nouveau truc que je vais goûter.
Donc ça, c'est
le premier et le premier truc.
Mais est ce que les industriels aiment
bien ?
C'est quand on les rachète
sur tous les produits ? Donc
les panels tests, les produits
et on les questionne
sur est ce que ça vous a plu
d'un point de vue gustatif ?
Et puis est ce que est ce que vous êtes
prêts à l'acheter ce produit là, s'il est,
s'il est exposé
dans un rayon de supermarché ?
Et puis surtout,
une fois que vous l'aurez acheté,
est ce que vous serez
enclin à le racheter ?
Donc tout ça,
on essaie de l'évaluer pour et puis.
Et puis en mettant, en mettant en regard
le degré
d'information qu'on donne au consommateur.
Par exemple, dire je remplace de
la protéine laitière produite ici.
Alors certes, avec un impact
environnemental peut être pas génial,
mais de la protéine de soja
qui va avoir le côté Ouais, c'est végétal,
mais ça vient d'Amérique du Sud
avec les impacts sur la déforestation,
avec tout l'impact du transport, et cetera
C'est peut être pas très vertueux. Donc
il faut qu'on
sache aussi éduquer et informer
le consommateur sur le fait que oui,
on a enlevé un peu de protéines animales
pour mettre de la protéine végétale,
mais c'est de la protéine,
plutôt de légumineuse,
qui est produite chez nous,
qui est transformée chez nous
et qui donne quelque chose au final,
qui est bon parce que c'est.
C'est alors le premier critère de choix,
c'est le prix.
Et puis après, il y a le goût quand même,
avant les aspects santé et tout ça.
Donc oui, c'est des
sur lesquelles on s'interroge.
Ce n'est pas nous qui faisons.
Il y a, il y a d'autres labos
warez ou autres qui qui sont spécialisés
là dedans et qui ont les outils
et les panels de dégustateurs pour
pour mener ces enquêtes là,
on parlait tout à l'heure
de la fermentation comme
un outil de conservation des aliments.
En ce moment
aussi, on parle beaucoup de l'énergie,
de son goût et de sa disponibilité.
Est ce qu'on peut imaginer finalement
développer la fermentation
pour développer aussi
une méthode de conservation
moins énergivore
que le frigo, par exemple ?
Eh bien oui, oui, ça,
c'est un des aspects qu'on met en avant
aussi dans la fermentation.
C'est la durabilité de ce procédé.
Parce que, en particulier
pour les fermentations végétales,
ça se fait à température ambiante.
Donc, contrairement au yaourt,
contrairement au lait,
il n'y a pas à chauffer.
Donc on prend, on prend le bocal,
on met le légume, on met un petit peu
d'eau, un petit peu de sel
et on laisse faire la nature
sur un coin de
sur une étagère de la cuisine.
Et on y revient dans un mois ou deux.
Il y a un tas de choses
qui qui se passent.
C'est très joli à voir.
Il y a des petites bulles,
ça peut changer de couleur,
mais en général,
on arrive avec un produit végétal
lacto fermenté
sans avoir mis une seule
kilo joules d'énergie.
On laisse juste faire la nature.
Donc ça, c'est un moyen de conserver
sans avoir besoin de réfrigérer,
ni de cuire, ni de rien.
Pour d'autres,
pour pour d'autres, pour d'autres aspects.
Finalement, oui, un produit fermenté,
un fromage par exemple,
en particulier les fromages
à extraits secs un peu élevés,
donc les fromages à pâte pressée cuite.
Cela, on peut se permettre de les garder
plusieurs jours
en dehors du frigo.
Un camembert, ça va le faire aussi.
Sauf qu'il va évoluer beaucoup plus vite
parce que l'activité de l'eau
est plus élevée.
Les micro-organismes
sont beaucoup plus agiles.
Et si on ne veut pas que le camembert
lui même devienne agile,
il vaut mieux le conserver
un peu au frigo quand même.
Mais autrement, oui, un comté,
un beaufort,
ça peut se conserver
à température ambiante un bon moment.
C'est un avantage de la fermentation,
justement.
C'est que la matière première
a été tellement transformée que ça
l'a aussi beaucoup stabilisé.
Est ce qu'il y a d'autres questions ?
Non. Peut être que pour terminer, on peut.
On peut faire un saut dans le passé.
Finalement,
si sait que nos ancêtres consommaient
des produits fermentés,
c'est grâce à l'archéologie, C'est ça ?
Oui, oui.
Alors pour pour la pour la partie lait
qui m'intéresse,
ce n'est pas mon domaine de recherche.
Mais par curiosité,
j'ai lu quelques articles là dessus
et en réalité,
on sait que l'homme consomme du lait
depuis le néolithique
qui correspond à l'époque à laquelle
il a commencé à domestiquer les ruminants.
Selon les latitudes,
ça a été des bovins, des ovins et caprins.
Et puis on imagine aussi que très vite,
il travaillait la vache en général.
Après, après la tétée du veau,
il travaille à la vache,
émettait ça dans un récipient.
Et puis finalement,
les premiers lait fermenté
consommés, ça a été
probablement des laits
de fermentation spontanée.
Et puis ils se sont dit
Toute façon, on peut laisser, ça a l'air
d'être bon encore une semaine après tout.
Tout ça était assez empirique,
en tout cas, on le pensait.
Et puis
exactement, à la même époque,
donc au néolithique,
il y a études archéologiques
qui ont été faites.
Des fouilles archéologiques ont été faits
qui ont mis à jour des poteries
où là où on passait.
Alors là, c'était plus de
la fermentation spontanée, juste
de la matière première l'est
et des micro-organismes.
Mais déjà, ces hommes là
avaient de la technologie et on le sait,
parce que dans ces poteries là,
c'étaient des poteries en deux morceaux.
En fait, il y avait le récipient.
Et puis, sur le dessus,
il y avait un autre récipient
qui lui contenait plein de trous.
Et là, on
parle de fromage de technologie fromagère
puisqu'il avait probablement le lait
qui avait caillé dans la jarre à côté
qu'on versait.
Donc le caillé,
on le versait dans ce truc là.
Le lactosérum goûtait et on obtenait
quelque chose qui avait un extrait sec
un peu plus fort,
qui probablement avait un autre goût
qui vieillissait différemment
un peu plus longtemps.
Et là, on avait les prémices
de la technologie fromagère
et on a su que c'était vraiment du lait
qui était
égoutté là dedans
parce que dans les poteries sont poreuses.
Et en analysant notamment les acides gras,
les lipide qui étaient contenus
dans ces petits trous des poteries, là,
on a vu que c'était oui.
C'était de la matière
grasse laitière, bovine
qui était là, présente dans ces jarres.
Donc dès le néolithique en fait.
Donc finalement, peu de temps
après la domestication des bovins,
l'homme s'est intéressé
à la technologie fromagère et a développé
un vrai savoir faire pour conserver
et modifier ce leur.
Est ce qu'il y a d'autres questions
pour terminer ce Café des sciences ?
C'est que ça a dû être plutôt clair.
Alors merci à tous d'être venus.
Merci à vous d'avoir pris le temps
de nous répondre à vous tous,
puis.